interested in machine learning on Google
Cloud but not sure where to start today
I'm going to walk you through the
process of how to pick the right AIML
Solution on vertex AI
before we dive in vertex AI is a fully
managed machine learning platform that
makes it easier to build train and
deploy models and AI applications
vertex AI has tooling for traditional
software development low coded no code
machine learning and custom model
training here are the three categories
we'll talk about today we'll compare the
differences and discuss how to choose a
right path for your use case so first we
have pre-trained models from the API
Library which allows developers to
incorporate models that Google owns and
maintains into their applications
pre-trained models are trained on a
large corpora of data and can provide
predictions for several General machine
learning problems client libraries are
available in many popular programming
languages
then we have automl which is a service
that allows developers to create models
for their own data without any model
training code this can be used if your
data is of a single type whether it be
image text tabular or video
this is accessible for users of all
backgrounds and finally custom model
training with open source Frameworks
develop your own custom model training
when your problem doesn't fit automl or
you want to write and configure your
model code with Frameworks such as
tensorflow Pi torch xgboost and more if
these Frameworks sound familiar custom
Training on vertex AI is for you next
we'll look at each of these options in
more detail let's start with the basics
no training or data needed your entryway
into incorporating AIML into your apps
pre-trained models if you have General
unstructured content you'd like to get
structured insights from using one of
our apis that encapsulates a pre-trained
model is your first stop
pre-trained apis are trained on a wide
breadth of data that is built updated
and maintained by Google so this means
you do not have to worry about creating
or managing the models behind the apis
let me walk you through a fun example so
the vision API allows you to classify
images detect objects logos and read
handwriting and much more so here's a
photo of my best friend's Pets the
vision API allows me to detect the
objects in the image such as the dog the
cat and the collar
you'll get back color information
cropping hints and other useful metadata
moving on to other data types we have
the video intelligence API which allows
you to do object detection streaming
video annotation and even set up
object-based event triggers
translation make your content and apps
multilingual with fast Dynamic machine
translation for over 130 languages
natural language derive insights from
unstructured text using natural language
understanding which is the use of AI to
perform reading comprehension tasks
this API allows you to perform tasks
such as entity extraction pulling key
terms and phrases such as proper nouns
public figures landmarks and more
sentiment detection get a score of the
writer's attitude or emotional opinion
positive negative or neutral so this can
be used to analyze and boost your
customers experience
content classification categorize bodies
of text which can then be used to guide
recommendations for your users
now we have the speech to text API you
can perform accurate speech
transcription from audio and video so
this API allows you to use over 20 years
of Google's experience in automated
speech recognition or ASR to increase
accessibility bring your apps to more
devices and deliver a better user
experience with content captioning and
Analysis
on the flip side we have the
text-to-speech API which uses
state-of-the-art research to provide
human-like speech synthesis while our
pre-trained apis cover a wide range of
capabilities how do you know whether you
should use one of our out-of-the-box
Solutions or use your own data to build
a model from scratch well if any of
these apply to you you may need to
develop your own model
you need a level of specificity for a
pre-trained model cannot provide for
example earlier the vision API can
identify the dog but if I needed the
specific breed of dog predicted I'd have
to train a model for this use case
another example is that I can get high
quality AI power translation using our
translation API but say I have a lot of
domain-specific terminology in my
content like if I worked in healthcare
or the legal field in that case I might
want to train a custom model to handle
the specification
if you require a high level of accuracy
and your team has the data the bandwidth
and the data science capability to
develop and maintain a custom model here
is where modeling on vertex AI comes in
there's a lot going on here but just
know with vertex AI you have support for
open source Frameworks end-to-end ml op
support to efficiently scale manage
Monitor and govern your workloads
tooling such as notebooks and pipelines
as well as optimize infrastructure for
every step of your journey vertex AI
offers two options to train models
automl and custom Training so here is
how to choose between these two options
automl allows us to deploy high quality
custom models with minimal effort and ml
expertise if your use case fits a
supported automl data type and objective
such as labeling and segmentation for
images or regression and classification
for tabular data start with automl again
the data types are image video text and
tabular there is no code required for
training because automl builds a model
for you when you use its no code
interface the console will walk you
through step by step the whole way
starting with importing your data into a
data set then training the model how to
evaluate the model's performance and
take you all the way through deploying
your model so you can get an endpoint
that you and call from your application
code
we recommend starting with automl to
prototype even if you are working in a
team with data science and machine
learning experts
but if your data is highly custom or
your model needs to take a mixed input
or you want control over the
architecture framework and exported
model assets it is time to start your
custom Training code Journey this is
where you can run custom Training jobs
to scale and operationalize your ml
training using pre-built or custom
containers the most common workflow we
see is creating and packaging up your
training application code configuring
the specifications for your custom
Training job submitting the job then
monitoring it as a trains training jobs
on vertex will automatically provision
Computing resources perform the training
task and ensure deletion of resources
once a training job is finished we hope
you enjoyed this tour of machine
learning on Google cloud and that you
find the right solution for your data
needs check out the links in the
description below to get started with
vertex Ai and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more Google Cloud
developer content
[Music]
foreign